Lily you shared a big scene with Tom
Brady like I thought he did really well
as an actor oh he is he's very good very
nice I hate sounding shocked but I was
yeah you know I just we don't like I you
know
I've made from Jessica Kelly not all of
us are actors I'm just saying like you
know what I'm saying we're not all there
and so it's it's it was it was
impressive I thought he did really
really well no he I was really quite
impressed too and and plea and I was
happy and pleased it was so natural and
he was such
[Applause]
together
um that's it that's just what I wanted
to say no I'm saying
um how did that go because you were you
were spooning weird yeah there was no
space for the Lord she
initiated the spoon all right well you
know I figured me and her character not
have known each other all our lives we
went to elementary school together and
we've had sleepovers when we were
younger and I always spooned her so why
not just because just because we're in
our 80s and she felt so good
just built right and we were just we
were we were loaded anyway
all four of us were oh my God that part
look at her eye she was like I'm not
saying anything
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]